Finding this place is never a problem
Zabbaleen. The city of rubbish collectors is surrounded by an accurate smell
that most people would find unbearable
This is where waste from the whole of Cairo are brought
No one ever saw police officer here
People live by their own rules
and also always happy to see stranger visiting
The region populated mainly by Coptic Christian, Egypt minority religion
Moslem lives here too,
but there is no religious conflicts in Zabbaleen
the dump guarantees interface peace
is the only local provider of work and liveliness
Kyrollos, and he is ten
He spent all his child in the rubbish collecting city of Zabbaleen
But he's one of the lucky ones
Unlike his peers
Kyrollos hasn't had to start doing any of the dirty work yet
Gerges inherited this job from his father
He was a refuse collector too
They came to Zabbaleen 45 years ago
and recycling techniques have barely changed in these years
Gerges Saad family collects, sorts, and cleans several different types of rubbish all the time
Typically, the men work with metal and plastic
Collecting and cleaning rubbish is a family concern
The women play their part too
They sort the food waste
Shekhata El-Mogaddis is one of the wealthiest people in Zabbaleen
He calls himself mayor of the city of rubbish collectors
but officially there is no such position
also rumor has it,
that Shekhata personally control the sale
of all glass at the recycling facilities
which they say generate fabulous profit for him
There's a villa with the luxurious pageant love
very close to the dump entrance
Shekhata never touches the rubbish himself
He just manages the process
He doesn't even clean his own house
He has a housekeeper for that
Shekhata, He is my uncle
because his father was rich since the beginning
90 percent of the community are poor
who are the regular garbage collector
who are relying on the garbage which they collect
Sort and sell to the recycler
There you see, family sorting
paper compactor
they are compacting using electrical compactor
We have our own live
We have groceries shop
We have buchos coffee shop, as you see
because men after collecting the garbage
they are very .... and come to the coffee shop
to drink tea or to smoke sisha
any problem or conflict is happening between each other
it's solved internally
The big leader of the family
He will respect the all people
So, once there is a problem
all people have a round table
"Oh, no.. , you should applogize to him, oh I'm sorry" All off
problem has finished
Never go to the police station
Never invite a police
We don't like them by the way
Because they come to make the problem more higher
The cops claim to be among the worlds, earliest Christian
They believe that their ancestors converted when Jesus still lived
and since then they always try to resolve problem peacefully
The Christian way
Gerges has working day, begins at 3.30 every morning
Avery Zabbaleen sign this a specific part of Egypt's capital
Collecting waste from a colleague territory is quickly taboo
All rubbish collectors religiously observe the unspoken rules
Look, each follow garbage is generating five daily jobs
Two are collecting from door to door
One is transporting
and two are sorting
So, it's five as the beginning
and as their saving indirect jobs,
who are recycling paper, plastic, metal, glass
each ton of garbage in Cairo is creating two well jobs
everyday
You see, this bag comes from the garbage
It's also make up
This is something for massage
You know what kind of massage is this?
I don't know. She knows (laugh)
She told me, read it carefully
you know, for ladies or men
All this things are in the garbage
So they sale such this stylee thing that people go to the market
and she's shouting
This carries biggest Friday market
It's near the city of rubbish collectors
People come to buy gifts for their nearest and dearest
and anything else they might need at home
No seriously
Kyrollos, his parents don't buy him toys
He can find everything that interest him in the dump
and that saves money
Returning to see Gerges Saad, we meet the butcher shop owner
Sameer Fatee
It's hard to imagine swine being kept in a Moslem country
but the Cops are Christians and pork is a staple part of their diet
Not long ago, pork was banned in Egypt
The Muslim brotherhood parliamentary majority
decided to have all the life stock in the country kelt
Including the Christian pigs of Zabbaleen
At that time, Zabbaleen started to sort the organic
in downtown and keep it in the container of the multinational companies
and the big street of Cairo, so Cairo is very bad smell and dirty
This went for two years
Then revolution on 21st of January
and Egypt, Zabbaleen come back again
animals
out of the system of the brand minister
He is debit your vice capitalism
but in the garbage collector is away from Cairo
no one care this thing
Cairo will be dying
Gerges Saad families meet with the pork or beef
only once a week, on Sundays
That's meat such an expensive treat
it can cost between 50 and 100 Egyptian pounds per kilo
That's 5 to 10 dollars
There is a local school in Zabbaleen
but not even that can guarantee Kyrollos education will allow him
to do anything other than collect and sort rubbish
Children study then they Mathematics
but refuse all the lessons tend to out away all of the subjects
Since the school open, 3 or 4 people have ever manage to escape from the dump
every one else has had little choice but to stay, live, and work here
There were farmers about 70 years ago
left their plant and come here
they don't have any other jobs
That so, I want to tell them
Yeah, this is your heads
They say no, we have our god immunity and so on
No, we have health problems
more than 42 percent of the community are infected of
We have also a lot diseases
We pay higher from our health, from our life
the average age of mortality is not more than 55 years
people are dying so young here